Android developer story
RAHUL GANJDO: Zomato as a brand new app
Allows you to browse the digital menu
Now we have opened in 24 cities.
Large food technology company
More than 150 million users visit our platform every month
We offer 10 languages
On the delivery side
We have 60,000 delivery drivers
If you want to find a fun place
Takeout, locator
Browse the food, you can use Zomato
Zomato needs to meet the needs of different users
This gives the development team
Brought a lot of challenges
PRATEEK SHARMA: I heard a lot of rumors about Kotlin.
I'm curious
How does it do an object-oriented model,
And solved at compile time
Schema vulnerability in the code
I almost understood it soon.
Kotlin allows me to develop more
Robust architecture application
At compile time, Kotlin provided us with
"null-safety" mode,
This is the most commonly used feature of our team.
If we can convert Java to Kotlin
The number of codes will be reduced by 15% to 20%
But if it is a data class,
The number of codes will be reduced by 55%
Thereby bringing huge improvements
Switching to Kotlin is not only effective, but also very interesting.
Now in Zomato, every function
Are based on Kotlin
Android developers like us
Have not used the functional paradigm used by JavaScript developers
So Kotlin can provide us with a function-oriented style of coding.
This is really great.
When we use the code of a third-party library,
There is usually a use case.
We want this class to have another function.
By using Kotlin's extensions
Simple to implement
All new Google SDKs and APIs
Have support from Kotlin
In addition to these, third-party library developers
Also added support for Kotlin,
This adds to our experience with Kotlin.
RAHUL GANJDO: Zomato's rating on Google Play Marketplace is 4.3.
We are very lucky
Can have an integrated system provided by Android
PRATEEK SHARMA: I recommend Kotlin
Because of its interoperability with Java
Through recent updates
Android Studio has greatly improved support for Kotlin
Almost barrier-free